Los Angeles
2023 as Society
unravels so what's the plan with the old
folks
home I'll just spray some mold in there
they'll all be dead in 3 months and we
can get on with the luxury highrise and
you will be mayor for another 4
years that's what I'm talking about in a
city constantly
evolving I'll kill you
[__] I'm Mike he h you [__] problem
with that one
man has remained the same oh my God
you're such a great mom oh thank you
thought I told you hor is to turn your
tricks down town come on Beat It a man
who lives by a
code
you know in my world there's three types
of people knock around
guys jerk
[Music]
offs and [__]
thems hello and it's my job to sort him
out what the [__] you [__] shot me
man what' you think was going to happen
you go around shooting at people some of
is going to shoot
Back Beach why it
Bingo oh that's the name of the
game a seemingly innocent
[Music]
man turns out to
be not so innocent chief I'd appreciate
if you give Mr Lee how shall I
say a wide birth you're make quite the
living
here
sorry me no speaker English he's a major
contributor to my campaign we got the
Olympics coming to town I don't need
this to become an issue am I making
myself clear 100% the Olympics are
coming to Los Angeles
soda yes sir a collision of [__] and
athletic events I don't give a [__] what
you noticed your job isn't to notice
things okay chief that's exactly my job
yeah if you don't shut the [__] up your
job is going to be noticing my foot up
your ass you got that Chief are you mad
at me one more harassment call from
[__] ye we whatever the [__] his name
is I have your gun and your match get
the [__] out of my
office
okay Jesus Christ
Mr re oh hello hello I know what you're
up to so from here on out I'm going to
be on you like white on rice you can't
say that that's
racist rice is white he happens to be a
pillar within the Kore town community
well sir with an international sporting
competition coming to the city I am very
concerned that some of his employees are
going to start a super gun Aria
pandemic
super that's not a
[Music]
thing it's super
ganaria
[Music]
no
power
[Music]
intri
appreciation Mr re me meet the Port of
Los Angeles we we have some unfinished
business from the people who brought you
Barbie does
Dallas I can't protect you anymore after
all the [__] up [__] I did for you bear
I
know they say there's a God huh Blanket
Bingo Beach Blanket
Bingo that's the name of the
game
prepare to meet God
hello I'm bleeding out man my leg's
going [__] numb don't worry you got
another
[Music]
[Applause]
leg Building A Better Community one
brick at a
[Applause]
time
soda soda
[Applause]
soda this Black Friday don't be a [__]
and bring your [__] to the movie
everyone is talking
about
so
hello